When it comes to PC Gaming, the monitor you
choose matters a whole lot more than most
people think.
Sure, you can buy any basic 1080p monitor
for around $100, but a gaming monitor is built
FOR gaming with gaming specific features.
So for this video, we’re comparing 4 of
the top gaming monitors under $200 to see
which one you should buy for your gaming needs.
And we’ll have links to these monitors in
the description.
The first one is a 24” curved monitor from
Sceptre for $163.
Then the 24” Zowie monitor from BenQ for
$199.
Then the 24” Acer Nitro monitor for $160.
And finally, a 27” monitor from Dell for
$180, which we’ve already covered in a previous
video for being the best selling gaming monitor
on Amazon, so check that out after this.
Before we get into build quality and design,
let’s compare the specs.
The resolution’s the same across the board
with Full HD 1080P, and for panel tech, the
Dell and BenQ get a TN panel, while the Sceptre
gets VA and the Acer gets IPS.
The difference is seen in a few different
things, mainly including response time, viewing
angles, color accuracy, price and refresh
rates.
For viewing angles, the Acer and it’s IPS
panel easily beats out the rest, and it’s
the same thing for color accuracy as well.
However, IPS panels are more costly to produce,
especially with high refresh rates, so that’s
why the Acer only refreshes at 75Hz compared
to 144Hz on the rest of these panels.
The 144hz model of this IPS monitor costs
a much higher $285.
And IPS panels typically have slower response
times, but with Acer’s Visual Response Boost
mode on, it’ll hit a 1ms respone time, but
some users complained about flickering issues
and monitor brightness going down with VRB
enabled, which may be an issue since it’s
already rated at only 250 nits of brightness,
with the Dell being rated up to 400 nits.
With Acer’s Visual Response Boost disabled,
response time goes up to 10ms, a lot slower
than the rest.
The BenQ monitor is the only monitor out of
the bunch that doesn’t support FreeSync,
a technology that helps get rid of screen
tearing and stuttering when FPS doesn’t
match the monitors refresh rate.
They all have VESA mounts, but the Sceptre
has a smaller 75x75mm pattern, so be aware
of that.
Now let’s compare the physical design of
the monitors.
From the front, the Acer looks the best with
the thinnest bezels overall and the best looking
stand out of the bunch.
The BenQ has huge bezels all around and an
enlarged area for the controls, not to mention
a massive and thick stand, so it’s not the
best choice for looks.
From the side, the sceptre is very thin and
sleek compared to the rest, and it’s the
only one that’s curved, but it’s very
subtle so it honestly doesn’t really change
much.
The BenQ and Acer are by far, the thickest
from the side.
Due to the Sceptre’s low profile stand,
the display sits closer to the wall than the
rest of the monitors, with the Dell in second
place and the BenQ’s display sitting the
furthest from the wall, so if you have a small
desk, the Sceptre wins here.
As for the stands, the Sceptre’s is the
only that’s made out of a solid piece of
aluminum, compared to plastic stands with
aluminum plates, and the Sceptre is by far
the sturdiest when you wiggle the desk, with
the larger BenQ and Dell wobbling the most.
As for adjustability, the BenQ destroys the
rest of the monitors with tilt, side to side
swivel, up and down height and 90 degree rotatation
adjustability for a vertical setup.
The rest of the monitors literally only tilt
forward and backward.
The main drawback is the lack of height adjustment
since some of these monitors sit pretty low.
As for cable management, the Dell and Acer
have basically none at all..
The Sceptre comes with a couple of plastic
clips that you can adjust and they work very
well, and the BenQ has a plastic clip on the
back which works great as well.
As for the cables that come in the box, the
Sceptre is the only one that comes with an
external power brick, the rest of them have
power supplies built into the monitor.
However, the Sceptre does come with a DisplayPort
cable, and same with the BenQ monitor as well.
The Dell comes with an HDMI 2.0 cable which
isn’t as good as having Displayport since
Nvidia cards require DisplayPort to support
AMD’s Freesync.
Now the Acer actually came with an ancient
VGA cable, which is so old that the budget
RX 580 from 2017 doesn’t support it, so
you’ll have to buy an HDMI cable for 75hz
since the monitor doesn’t support Displayport.
Now onto I/O, the Acer is limited to two HDMI
1.4 ports, a VGA port, an audio in port for
using your monitor’s speakers when you’re
using VGA, and a headphone jack.
The Sceptre comes with two clearly labeled
HDMI ports, a DisplayPort also capable of
144hz and a headphone jack.
The Dell has HDMI and DisplayPort both capable
of 144hz, a headphone jack and two USB 2.0
ports for peripherals.
The BenQ comes with a Displayport, a Dual-link
DVI port capable of 144hz, and an HDMI port
which I believe is limited to 60hz.
It also has a headphone jack on the left side
which may be more comfortable to use, and
it’s the only one without built-in speakers,
which honestly doesn’t really matter.
Now firing them up, let’s compare the Menu
controls and UI.
The Dell has clearly labeled controls on the
front that are very easy to use, and the UI
is very simple and works perfectly.
The Sceptre has 3 buttons on the back which
you’ll have to take a look at to understand
and it’ll take some time getting used to
before you stop accidentally hitting the wrong
ones.
The UI is a bit cluttered but it works okay
overall.
The Acer has a joystick that can be used to
change every setting and it works really well,
along with 3 more buttons used to quickly
change things like input and brightness.
The UI is simple and looks better than Dells.
However, when you turn on 1ms response time
VRB mode, the screen dims like crazy and Freesync
actually turns off, so you can’t get both
at the same time.
You’ll be stuck at a horrible 10ms response
time if you want FreeSync and a bright display.
Onto the BenQ, it has an unnecessary bulge
on the right side for its unlabelled controls
which don’t work very well because the UI
was a pain to use compared to the rest of
the monitors.
And finally, we did some gaming playing Fortnite
on each monitor to test out how each well
each monitor performed.
The Sceptre played pretty well at 144hz using
FreeSync and we didn’t notice any issues
with gameplay, except that the display was
a bit dim.
The Dell also played great at 144hz, there
were no issues and I loved how it was super
bright and the colors look pretty good!
The BenQ, however, seemed to play at 144hz
pretty well despite not having FreeSync, with
great brightness and decent colors as well.
Now the Acer was another story, it’s limited
to 75hz, so as you can see in this slow-mo
comparison, it’s definitely not as smooth,
and since the 1ms virtual response boost mode
dims the brightness, adds flickering and disables
FreeSync, I turned it off and dealt with 10ms
response time, so it didn’t feel that smooth
compared to the rest.
Because of that and the fact that it comes
with a VGA cable, the Acer is out, leaving
the other three.
The BenQ was in 3rd place for having the huge
bezels, being very bulky overall with bad
controls and the worst UI, along with the
lack of FreeSync.
We did enjoy all of the adjustability and
good brightness, but it’s the most expensive
at $199.
The Sceptre just barely got into 2nd place
by being priced at $160.
The 144hz support with either HDMI or DisplayPort
was excellent, and along with the low profile
design with the sturdiest stand helped outweigh
the negatives of the dimmer display and subpar
menu controls.
And the winner is..
The Dell, for quite a few reasons.
You get 144hz with either HDMI or DisplayPort.
It’s the only one that packs 2 USB ports.
You get FreeSync, a low 2ms response time,
the brightest display of all of these, and
the largest at 27”, with pretty slim bezels
as well.
The controls are simple and intuitive, and
Fortnite played great at 144hz.
The only downsides are the slightly less sturdy
stand and the lack of cable management.
Other than that, there’s really no compromises
at a great price of $180, and that’s why
it’s the winner.
If you want to learn more about it, check
out our video review of the Dell after this
video.
We’ve left links to the best deal on all
of these monitors in the description below,
so if you enjoyed this video and you’ve
made your decision, use those links below
to help support us and click the button above
to subscribe!
This has been Vadim with Max Tech, thanks
for watching and we’ll see you in the next
video!